guys I'm so excited to talk to you both
today thank you so much for your time uh
just so you know start off really fun oh
fun little warm up kind of marred maybe
in some stressful situations if you were
ever issued a red notice by accident on
against you who was the first person
you're calling wow I don't I really
don't know I'm like if somebody was
trying to trying to do me a lot I don't
know me as a human being are made the
character chelfa
Domingo Chavez absolutely I want him on
my side yeah I would probably uh
set a reminder to myself to protect
myself right
of course so you know this
is so phenomenal and I love this show
since the start and to have you
on the season this year was just so good
to see both of you fleshed out these
characters
um but you're both brand new characters
to the Jack Ryan series and coming in no
less on the final season so was there an
added pressure or challenge that you
felt making these characters fit into
the universe with these like seasoned
vets so to speak yeah there was I'm like
first it was a throw obviously because
you want to be part of a cool show and
then for sure it was nerve-wracking
because you didn't want to mess it up
and you didn't want to be the one guy
that that like just doesn't Vibe with
everyone else like you don't want to be
the guy that's like doing something too
different
um and but you want to just kind of be
part of the the team you know that that
tells a story yeah it's a murderer's row
of actors you know down in the smallest
guest star so you don't want to be the
guy yeah you're gonna bring your A game
to this show yeah there's a little bit
Yeah there's there's so much that
happens in this season and you know
Michael you are a brand new Clancy
character in The Ryan verse and I'm
curious when there is a character that's
so beloved in the books how do you
create a balance of of what you bring to
the character and what this character is
to the entire fan base well he's like
he's a stealthy kind of quiet guy and
I think you kind of have to stick to
that in a way and of course it's got to
be like that that kind of like version
of yourself right
um so I I try to stay true to that and
then you know just add a couple things
here that don't diverge Too Much from
the actual character
um and you know because there was times
where I'm like I want to joke around but
I was like it's not this character
that's not how he would be so you kind
of have to fight some some performer
instincts and just really focus on
telling the story yeah I feel like there
were some you know times when I was
watching it felt like there was like
improv like you added a little bit of
humor because like just a little bit a
little bit Yeah but it really
complemented it the whole scene nicely
so I think that really worked out but it
was interesting though because it wasn't
just like telling a joke for the jokes
it's something that the character
thought it was funny so it was that's
how you got away with it a little bit
Yeah and Louie you were on another
Amazon show hunters and so I'm curious
what has been the most surprised thing
you realize with these levels of
production that Amazon so wonderfully
captures especially with Jack Ryan that
is such a worldwide show they go to so
many different countries and they make
it really glamorous but like also very
relevant for fans oh man how lucky to be
I was on one Temple and then to jump on
to another I was literally in Prague
finishing season two of hunters uh when
I got a call about Jack Ryan and uh I I
went home for two weeks and flew
straight to Budapest to begin yeah so
yeah it's very fortunate very cool I I
feel like I'm spoiled and
um I this is the kind of it's a high bar
it's a high bar let's just put it that
way the stunts on this show they really
Elevate the action to what feels like a
theatrical experience everything is so
well done knowing that John was thrown
out of a helicopter in season three what
was the hardest stunt for you guys in
this past season well I mean being
thrown out of two helicopters
that's uh no no I for me literally it
wasn't anywhere near that I was like I
literally jumped into like a like a
puddle of water
um no because I can't swim so I'm like
me swimming like 10 yards uh to me was a
big deal and uh so that was my big
you know my big deal yeah for me was uh
jumping into a moving car while the rear
uh windshield was blowing up that was
that's a first for me I've done some
things I've jumped off of buildings and
The Bourne Legacy ridden motorcycles on
camera but that was a first for sure
um what is the biggest thing you two are
going to take away from this series you
get to be
Wendell and my
my aunt on the show what was the biggest
thing for both of you I mean to me it
has to be the experience with Lily and
Mike Kelly Wendell uh you know everyone
else in the cast like it's a special
group and they work so well together and
you can see why
um at first like I felt like a little
bit of an outsider and then I'm like I
was able to to break through a little
bit and so I could just imagine like
what it would be like to to have four
years together and then I was able to
witness the last scene that John was in
and he gave a beautiful speech and
everyone else came in and it was um you
know something that I'll never forget
um so before I do let you go Michael I
know there's been talk for a spin-off
series for Chavez and I'm curious what
that looks like especially since the
final season does tee up some new
Dynamics especially like Chavez's
Bromance I would say with Mike November
um can you speak to some of that or at
least tease like what fans can expect I
don't know I mean I mean it was
bromantic
um but uh
you know it's up to the fans and up to
Amazon and you know there's a lot of
people that have to do certain things
but you know people like it maybe
they'll they'll chime in and say like
hey we want some more and so you know we
leave it in their hands yeah well I
would personally love more Shabbos I
thought you were a great addition to the
show and guys thank you so much for your
time and on that note congratulations
I'm so pumped for everyone to see this
uh season it's phenomenal thank you so
much